you
[Music]
I won't really talk about the meandering
path that got me to this role I will
talk a little bit about my Wall Street
experience during the talk right now I'm
at a company called Zora and well I
should also say fighting chairman data
is the name of a book that I'm writing
so this is kind of previews from the
book and I obviously don't have a
graphic designer
yet so I made that terrible image by
myself but don't worry we'll get a
better cover before there's actually a
book coming out it's a little bit about
Zora Zora is the leading subscription
management platform I guess leading is a
subjective statement but you know we are
a subscription management platform and
we have many customers on the platform
hopefully some of which you've heard of
what these companies all have in common
is that they sell a product buy a
subscription and they're using Zora to
manage the subscriptions the way I
explained Zora is to say that you want
to sell a product by subscription if you
just charge everyone $9.99 a month
that's actually pretty easy that's an
easy subscription billing use case if
it's something like your cell phone plan
where you've got like a base plan
multiple devices allowances of data
allowances of other resources then you
have a very complicated subscription and
it's actually hard to get everyone's
bills right and make sure that you're
charging everyone so part of this is
about charging people for you know using
your product but it's also just about
designing your subscriptions and plans
making sure everyone's you know getting
the service and integrating it all with
your financial back-end so I'm going to
say a little bit more about three
specials or our customers because these
are customer case studies in the talk
today and there are generously allowing
me to show you their data real data
about their churn and that their
products so let me briefly introduce
them because that you know that they do
this for the marketing I guess so
broadly is a SAS company you guys all
know SAS or software as a service so
broadly as a SAS company broadly ensures
that your business looks great online
and is found and chosen by potential
customers
so it helps companies manage their
reviews and things like that online clip
folio is a data analytics cloud app for
building and sharing real time business
dashboards so it's like a bi tool that I
guess there's I don't know if it's
similar to mode that we just were kind
of talking about or different I'm not
actually that expert versa tourism
communications company versa tourism the
Canadian tell Canadian telecom industry
with cloud-based business communication
solutions so it's voice over IP for
mostly small businesses in Canada in
fact all these products are mostly used
by small businesses so moving on what is
churn for anyone who doesn't know I as
you probably know if you're in the room
but in case not churn means cancellation
of subscriptions on a subscription
product or generally it can mean just
anyone leaving your product if you have
any product where you want people to
keep coming back like an app or
something if they stopped coming back
then you can consider that a churn and
everything I'm going to talk about today
applies equally to non-subscription
products as to subscriptions it's just a
little it's the definitions are all
clearer when we're talking about
subscription so I'm gonna focus on on
that the term churn originated from
what's called the churn rate which is
the proportion of subscribers that
cancel in a given time period so when
your subscribers are canceling you need
to replace them it leads to a turnover
in your subscriber pool and that's why
they call it churn Tron originally means
to mix something churn is also now a
verb you can say the customer churned or
the customers churning it's also a noun
make a list of all the churns from last
quarter and you know we're gonna work
over that list of churns so the word has
taken on kind of a life of its own I'm
not going to say a lot about churn raids
in this talk I make a report for my
company
Zhora called the subscription economy
index and if you want benchmarks to know
what our typical churn rates and
different verticals you should look at
this report but we're not really going
to talk about specific churn rates of
any company
in this talk because my case study
companies won't let me tell you their
churn rates it's actually very sensitive
information so we're gonna talk a lot
about churn I'll just say generally you
know we see average churn rates in the
20 to 30% a year
I think the top 10% best churn rates in
Zorah is kind of like below 10% and the
top 10% worst churn rates in Zorah have
annual churn rates above 60 or 70
percent I forget the exact number so we
see you know all across the board
different churn rates so what is
fighting churn with data about this is
one of my kind of terrible diagrams that
needs a graphic designer from the book
but it's the mental model for what the
book is about the general situation is
shown here on the Left where you have
some kind of product you have users
they're using the product and you're
gonna track that in some kind of data
warehouse exactly what you're tracking
depends on your situation if you
actually have subscriptions you've
probably got another database that's
tracking the subscriptions so that's the
situation that you come into the goal
that you want is kind of hiding here on
the bottom not a great design but you
want more retention and engagement with
your customers retention is basically
the opposite of churn so if you say
you're going to increase retention
that's the same thing as reducing churn
and you need to increase engagement so
the book is about taking the data that
you've got in your subscription database
and data warehouse putting them together
and doing a churn analysis which we're
gonna see examples of and once you've
done that you can segment your
subscribers or customers into different
groups and take targeted actions to try
to do something about the churn so the
book is mostly about this analytic part
but we do talk a little I will say
something about you know what you're
actually gonna do about churn I think
that's actually the well we're getting
to that into that on the next slide but
I like to tell people that churn is
actually pretty hard to fight and it
kind of sets the context for much of the
work that I have done there first of all
churn is hard to predict and that's
because much of the information that you
would need to predict
well is not gonna be available to you
particularly you don't know about
people's ability to pay you don't know
what they're up often czar and you don't
really know what they think of your
product when it comes down to it
subjectively even when it's completely
obvious that someone's gonna churn the
timing is still unpredictable and we'll
see examples when it's really obvious
who's gonna churn but you still don't
really know when they're gonna do it and
that's probably a common experience for
all of us if you think about the last
time you canceled Netflix or Hulu you
probably didn't watch something for a
few months and you're like oh I gotta
cancel that thing oh I got I got billed
for it again I got to cancel it and the
time when you finally cancel it has to
do with all these other you know factors
which a data analyst or data scientist
could never really know about not only
is turned hard to predict it's even
harder to prevent because there's really
well there's no silver bullets I mean
there's no easy ways to prevent churn in
a you know ongoing and significant way
you really have to deliver more value
it's what we call like a lead bullet
situation it's like the zombies just
keep on coming and you better have a lot
of lead bullets cuz they're not there's
not just one trick that's gonna do it or
if there is one trick that improves your
churn it's probably a sign of a major
product gap or a failure in your product
design but assuming you have a decent
product no major bugs you're not gonna
find easy fixes for churn and I also
like to point out that discounting is
not a strategy to reduce churn a lot of
people in a data science course they're
given a churn dataset and given an
exercise suppose you send a discount to
everyone who you predict is gonna churn
you know something along those lines how
much money would you save but sending
out discounts is not a way that real
companies try to reduce churn or it's
usually not very successful you give
discounts to lure people into signing up
but there's no such thing as like a last
month half off because everyone would
just take the last month half off right
it's your last month you might as well
get half off so it's really subverting
the pricing strategy to use discounts so
what do you do
churn is hard to fight because
preventing churn is owned by the
business people and not just one kind of
business person it's owned by
different parts of your organization
product creators are gonna reduce churn
by making a more engaging and stickier
product marketers can help reduce churn
but it's not marketing in the sense of
increasing sales you've got to market
your features the best features of your
product to your customers to make sure
that they're aware of them and taking
advantage of the best features of your
product customers success and support
are groups that do one-on-one
interventions with customers if it's a
reactive intervention like the customer
calls and complains and that's customer
support customer success usually means
that you're more proactive you're
designing onboarding training maybe even
reaching out to people who you know are
failing and lastly account managers can
work on churn by right sizing the
pricing plan for a customer and by right
sizing I mean getting someone on the
right plan for them it's not the same as
discounting because if you think
someone's already on the right plan you
don't discount but if you really think
someone's you know on an inappropriate
plan then you know fine you can you know
take a down cell rather than churn and
lastly I want to emphasize these are
four different groups they've all got
their own tools as well so if you want
to do something like deploy a machine
learning model you're gonna have some
issues in fact let's go on to the next
slide and talk about the role of data so
I show a little Venn diagram here of a
sort of the three main sort of areas of
data work data science machine learning
and data analytics and then I'm saying
fighting churn with data lives mostly in
data analytics because basically what
you've got to do is test hypotheses and
explain the results to these all these
different people in your company that
are all gonna have their different tools
the most important thing you can
actually do is design the behavioral
metrics which I'm going to spend most of
the time talking about in this in this
talk you can help design segments and
that's where you might get to predict
churn with something like a predictive
model but the thing is if you're
predicting churn with a model it needs
to be in a
means that these people understand that
it also needs to be in their tool the
sales guys are all using the CRM the
customer support people are all using
Zendesk the marketing people they need
to make their segments in their their
email marketing automation tool like
Marketo or MailChimp or you know
whatever you've got so the most
important thing and what I'm gonna focus
on in this talk is what I call metric
design with the business people if you
have a data science or statistics
education you've called this feature
engineering I don't call it feature
engineering with the business people
because if you're in a software company
you've got software features and you've
got software engineers when you start
talking about feature engineering you
can get you can really confuse people so
one of my themes in this is speaking the
language of the business so I'm gonna do
that in many cases we're going to talk
about metric design and not feature
engineering even though you can know
it's the same thing so it's your
not-so-secret weapon I mean if you're
kind of new to this field you might not
have had this experience but really the
feature engineering can be the most
important thing you do when you approach
any problem you can prove interpretable
hypotheses and business people will
believe it and act on it you can do a
dimension reduction that is not
confusing to people I'll show you about
that in this talk and you'll be able to
accurately predict with any model
including a linear model if you do a
good job on your future engineering so
let's talk about what features I'm
talking about this is converting the
data in your data warehouse into summary
metrics and I'm sure many of you have
done exercises like this before this is
a hypothetical example you have user
logins and these are events that happen
at any time for each user when you make
a metric out of it or what I call a
metric it means you divide the series of
events into Windows and in this case you
just I'm saying you just count them you
know how many logins per month or four
in a four week period if your events
have additional data with them like if
there are transactions then you could do
things like the total dollar value in a
particular period or if there are
durations like for watching videos or
to music you would do the total or the
average time viewed and things like that
and I would consider these you notice
your basic metrics and we're gonna look
at more advanced metrics soon
one thing I'll mention before moving on
is we do these in a staggered way so
even though you're observing behavior
and say a one month period it doesn't
mean you have to wait a month to update
it you make a moving window and every
day you can update you know your one
month moving window of whatever you
update the metrics all the time and then
you're gonna form a data set which is
again probably something many of you
have already done to form a churn data
set I want to emphasize a few points you
need to make observations of both churn
and renewal events and you make these
observations in advance of the event and
you make it why do you make it in
advance well after someone's churned
they're obviously off your system so
they'll have all zeros right but right
before they turn they might change their
behavior - I'm making a hypothetical
example here where it's a file sharing
service where you have like uploads and
downloads before someone's gonna turn
they'll probably stop uploading because
they're like am done with this place I'm
not contributing anymore but they're
gonna download like crazy you know
because they're like oh I got to get
everything but you know before I'm cut
off so it would be easy to detect people
churning in this time when they're
preparing to churn but you actually want
to go even further back than that - when
they're still thinking about it
and it's hard to know exactly when that
is but you just kind of figure say it's
a month-to-month subscription maybe one
to two weeks before the renewal that's
when you should make the snapshot and
then you later on you see if they're a
churn or a renew for an annual
subscription you'll use an even longer
lead time maybe one to three months
before the renewal that's when you need
to look and see how are they doing and
then later on you'll see if they return
and then you flatten that data set is
that you know kind of a picture of
flattening the data set and you figure
out who's a churn or not from the
subscriptions all right so finally after
all that preparation I think we can
start looking at some actual churn
analysis so I manage
showing you this technique and it's
actually the only analytic technique I'm
gonna present today it was a little bit
funny when Peter was asking me what do
you want to present what model do you
use I was a little bit like um I think I
said regression because we do use
regression but it's not really a model
driven approach that I take these are
cohort plots which basically means I
sort the users or subscriber is all by
one variable and divide them into
cohorts typically deciles and then you
look at the average churn rate in each
death aisle and just make a plot like
this so this is saying you know these
bottom deciles of the clip folios active
days per month have a much higher churn
rate than people who are active like 20
or more days a month I'm not showing you
the numbers here because like I said I
can't tell you anyone's churn rate but
in all of these plots these are the this
is the true zero right so when you see
you know this churn rate here is you
know half of this churn rate whatever it
is and I don't even need to show you the
churn rates to explain this to you
because the plots look like this no
matter what the churn rate is like I
said I've worked with companies with 1%
churn rate I've worked with companies
that have 50% churn rate these plots
still look the same and I like to show
these to the the business users because
they can reproduce this analysis
themselves which is something you might
have heard when you demonstrate a result
to people in the business they'll be
like oh I want to reproduce that or who
are those accounts you say oh the these
accounts are hardly logging in they'll
say who are those accounts I want to
look at those accounts and with this
kind of analysis you just say here you
go here's the spreadsheet sort it
however you want you can reproduce the
same analysis a hundred percent in a
spreadsheet which is very effective
talking to business users and getting
them to you know believe in you so
here's an example from broadly the
reviews updated per month so updating
reviews is one of the main features and
it's interesting just to make another
example here we're here if they get
above 2 to 4 reviews updated a month
they're pretty much good you know and
people
customer success and support they always
want rules like that Oh what do I have
to get the users above it can be hard in
a case like this one where really it's
just the more the better
I mean I guess you could say that after
around ten days a month they're pretty
good but it doesn't always give you a
clean oh just above this number for them
so even though I'm not gonna do a lot of
like modeling there is some math in this
and one thing I wanted to point out is
using a log scale scoring so scoring I
mean normalization or standardization
again this is like a business user lingo
I like to say scoring because they're
not intimidated when you say oh we're
gonna give everyone a score they're like
cool it's like baseball or basketball or
something like that you say
normalization and they're like oh what's
that so these are cases where the
behavior there's a long tail for example
and customers added per month for
broadly the top 10% is above 300 but you
you know how people with practically
none for versus or local calls per month
the top 10% seems to be above 30,000 and
again that's oh that's a long tail and
when you make a score from these take
the log of one plus the count for a
count metric and then just do the normal
subtract the mean divided by the
standard deviation and then you can make
these plots that look like this and you
can see you know it's kind of a lint
this one was kind of a linear
relationship and you know in log scale
and I also find this is a great way to
introduce scoring to business people
because you I can actually show them
these two plots and see like look how
when you do without the score all the
points are bunched up down on the left
right but when I turn it into a score it
looks like all smoothed out and they'll
nod their heads and say okay yeah that
kind of looks better and then I'll just
say so that's why we do scoring because
it makes these plots look better and now
you all know there's a lot of other
reasons to do scoring some of which
we're gonna get to but it's kind of a
good way to just sort of sneak in the
concept you know to business people so
let's look at some more examples
okay account tenure is what I call the
age of someone on the
after how long have they been on your
product I don't call it the age because
that's confusing with you know the age
of an individual if it is an individual
and you these are very typical
relationships you see the highest churn
rates like in the first year even a peek
around in the cohort that includes one
year because you know fewer people are
gonna churn kind of mid year and then
over multiple years the churn rate you
know decreases and these are kind of
your standard expected relationships
with account tenure they don't always
look this way there are products where
churn increases with tenure it's kind of
a special case and it's not always a bad
thing I guess I can talk about that
later if we have time but let's look at
some other stuff monthly recurring
revenue is the amount paid per month if
you're already in the SAS or
subscription world you probably already
know about em ar-ar-ar-ar so it's a
slowly changing dimension or metric and
that someone's m RR only changes when
they switch plans but I still calculate
it as a metric you know every week or
whatever to do a unified analysis with
all the other behavioral metrics so now
let's ask the trick question does paying
more cause people to churn alright who
thinks people who pay more atern more
all right I told you it's a trick
question paying less turn more all right
here's some data usually people who pay
more churn less it's not always true
it's almost always true though and these
are typical examples I like to show real
data because it's you know gonna be a
noisy relationship also I'll mention I'm
not showing any real monthly recurring
revenue I'm only showing you the scores
because I'm not here to tell you about
the pricing information of these
companies but these are you know pretty
typical examples where you see people
who pay more generally churning less now
why the first reason is what's called
involuntary churn which means people who
want to continue the product but they
can't pay so it makes sense that people
who signed up for a more expensive plan
are going to have less involuntary churn
because they had more money to begin
with right
they wouldn't have signed up for the
expensive plan this is especially true
in business-to-business products where
you're more expensive people probably
pay ten or a hundred times you're less
expensive people I know and Zora you
know are more expensive you know paying
customers or like have million-dollar
your contracts and their billion
dollar-a-year companies and then we've
got startups who are only paying us you
know ten thousand a year and those
startups just go out of business but the
billion-dollar corporations don't but
this the involuntary churn doesn't
entirely explain why more higher M RR is
associated with less churn it's really
about correlation and not causation so
here's an example of a little
correlation in turn analysis from versa
M R R is positively correlated with the
number of devices the amount of domestic
calls in the amount of local calls now
that shouldn't be surprising because hi
m RR means they're a bigger company they
have you know more devices and more
users so when you look at these things
in churn it's actually well they're all
related to churn so churn is lower among
people who do all these things and that
is a good way to think about why M are
you know is correlated with less churn
you know not more churn because they're
just bigger users overall they have all
these good things going for them so
talking more about correlation when you
look at a SAS product they're typically
tracking dozens or you know even
hundreds of events usually more events
than I want to deal with for this kind
of analysis and when you look at a big
correlation matrix of all of the
different events it generally looks like
this and there'll be a big hot spot when
you sort it there'll be a big hot spot
of all the most common events you know
on the platform and then you get these
other blocks of correlated activity
related to other things so this is from
clip folio the main block is all metrics
of dashboard viewing and editing and
then these lesser blocks are more
specialized so working with templates
all the metrics in this block this block
has to do with bringing in new data
sources etc so you're always gonna have
these big groups of correlated stuff in
a SAS product so what do we do about it
now we're talking about dimension
reduction and the problem with dimension
reduction is that it's hard to explain
if you've ever had the pleasure of
trying to explain PCA to business people
I don't know anyone it's not fun they
they just don't get it and it is
actually a PCA is kind of confusing so
here's another method that I've used
hierarchical clustering also known as
agglomerative clustering you basically
just take the correlation matrix you
find the two most correlated things and
you merge them by weighted average of
the scores and you use sum of squares
weighting to preserve the variance it's
similar to PCA in that respect
recalculate your correlations and you
just repeat that met that method until
either all the remaining correlations
are below a threshold or you achieve a
target number of blocks and this is
actually how I produced this correlation
matrix by doing the agglomerative
clustering and resore take now is this
really a dimension reduction method well
I like to show these plots which compare
hierarchical cluster errs to PCA so on
the left here is the loading matrix for
the first six principal components from
PCA and on the right is the loading
matrix from hierarchical clustering and
what's very interesting about these
comparisons is the groups that were
found by the hierarchical clustering are
really prominent in the PCA loadings so
this you know this hot block in the PCA
that corresponds directly to the second
block found through agglomerative
clustering and similarly for all these
other things going on in the PCA loading
matrix they're very similar to the
hierarchical clustering so yes this is a
real dimension reduction method which
does a lot of the same thing that PCA
does and it's really easy for people to
understand so when I show businesspeople
that core
and matrix and say look all these
behaviors are correlated well sometimes
you have to explain to them what
correlation means first but after you do
that you can show them the heatmap they
like that it's like you know cool colors
and it actually shows them what they
already know and then they'll accept
plots like this where I say okay I made
an average score on the dashboard
viewing and editing metric group and it
you know has this relationship to churn
and so this is again a very natural way
to introduce dimension reduction to the
business as well because you've kind of
built up the context about churn
reducing behaviors oh but these
behaviors are related so we'll look at
them all together and then this is the
template and metrics group that was the
second block of related behavioral
metrics also for these are all examples
from clip folio so you can you know do
this simple dimension reduction it you
should do this because the behaviors are
correlated I mean you're the data person
and you understand all this so even if
you don't tell them everything about
correlation you at least need to
understand it okay but what about
differences now what's interesting about
PCA and comparison to hierarchical
clustering is the PCA matrix has all
this information about what are the
interesting differences like what things
tend to go together and then it makes
additional information out of the
differences between the normalized
variables that's cool but it's really
hard for people to understand so how do
we what else can you do I say I take
this from The Wall Street playbook and
I'm gonna take a short detour into
company analysis where you have a
related problem if you want to analyze a
company there are many measures of the
company but they're all correlated the
share price the earnings the dividends
the number of shares these are all big
numbers for Apple and Google and they're
very small numbers you know for like a
penny stock or you know any small
company so there's a lot of correlation
and financial data so what financial
people do is they look at ratio metrics
like earnings per share I'm sure you've
heard of price earnings price divided by
earnings dividend yield is the dividend
divided by the price
so four so you these types of metrics
make companies of different sizes
comparable if you want to know if the
stock is expensive or cheap you look at
the price earning ratio not just at the
price right so you can take this trick
and use the same thing in your own
metrics okay one note I like to make is
how intuitive this is I no one's ever
explained this to me so if you study
cognitive psychology and can tell me why
this is true I'd like to know but ratios
are really intuitive like if you say
miles per hour we all know that what
that is but if you make the unit of a
mile hour by multiplying miles times
hours you're kind of like huh and the
business users are too so humans just
seem to have a natural understanding of
ratios but not for unit multiplication
and I don't know why that is but we
definitely take advantage of it by
making ratios that people were
understand so from the work I've done I
summarized it as three key ratios to
look for when you're designing metrics
related to churn utilization is actually
the most common one whenever there's a
budgeted resource you want to look at
what percent of it people are using and
everyone's actually already doing that
already so if you have a budgeted
resource you want to know who's near the
limit what's not so common is to look at
metrics of efficiency and value and I
would define an efficiency metric as any
kind of completion or success rate and
the value metric as any ratio where one
of the things is the cost
so it's either cost divided by use or
use divided by cost and I'll make
examples of these right now here are
some value metrics for Versa tour and
this goes back to the question of do
people who pay more churn less or more
well now we can actually see that people
who pay more churn more when it's price
per call so people who pay more
generally making more calls but when you
actually AM normalize what they're
paying by the amount of calls that
they're making then you see the real
relationship yes people who pay more
churn more same this is dollars
per dollar it's you know the opposite
ratio I don't really have a strong
belief or feeling about which one you
should be using but if you want to see
the one we're paying more means more
churn you put the the what they're
paying in the numerator also here's the
m RR per device not as strong our
relationship but you know still a real
relationship I'd say here and what's
interesting if you look at these
correlations down here is that mor you
know is correlated with things like you
know the the number of device and total
calls per month but it's not very
correlated you know if you look at this
m RR per call it's not super correlated
with anything except its reciprocal
right so this is actually like you are
reducing the dimension and making new
features here which are not as well
correlated with the others okay so let's
look at another example this is a
success or failure case this is from
broadly so they want reviews right but
are they good reviews or bad reviews so
here the customer promoter per month is
the number of you know positive reviews
per month and as you would expect the
more positive reviews the less churn
right but what about detractors those
are bad reviews if you look at customer
detractor per month
you also see oh look more bad reviews
less churn does that make sense well it
does from the sense of correlation that
if you get a lot of reviews you're going
to get a lot of bad reviews you want to
see the real impact of bad reviews you
have to look at the detractor rate so
here you can really see that if you're
getting a high proportion of detractors
above 15 or 20% it's actually bad news
and so that's the relationship you were
expecting to find with detractors but
you don't find it when you just look at
detractors alone and last example well I
shouldn't want to add for this this also
technique applies for almost any
situation where you want to know like
what is better one feature or another or
one type of content or another because
you're generally gonna find your power
users consume a lot of everything and
they don't turn as much and you're slow
you know you're weak users are going to
low numbers on everything and they'll
churn but you have to look at the actual
ratio or you know the relative
difference between the features with a
percentage or some kind of ratio and
that's how you can answer questions
about you know which one is better and
they don't always look this good
I mean look obviously I took some really
great examples to put in the
presentation you'll see you'll do this
exercise some times and you'll find no
relationship oh well you know move on
you know but if you can find a few key
relationships like this that's what
really makes the difference in your turn
analysis okay lastly utilization I put
this one laughs because almost everyone
has a utilization metric already and the
result is basically what you would
expect you've got active users of course
the more active users the better the
number of seats is sold is not a super
strong relationship but it does kind of
show okay the big customers who have
really a lot of seats there is a you
know somewhat lower churn rate
reasonably convincing difference but you
want to see a really clear and strong
relationship you look at the license
utilization and don't ask me why some
people have more than one hundred
percent license utilization
they just do you know in some companies
so but again this is it's the same
concept with license utilization you can
make a metric which is not so correlated
with just the size or the number of
people in the company so that's actually
all I'm gonna try to say for today
fighting churn is not easy it requires
data people to actually make examples
that business people can understand and
really transfer knowledge to them which
is why I consider this more of like a
data analytics task than like a data
science task well design metrics allow
you to analyze and predict Turin and
interpretable way and the most important
tip I'm trying to communicate in today's
talk is about making ratios of simple
metrics they're usually interpreted
Balazs an efficiency measure a
utilization metro measure or a value
measure and they have this effect of
letting you kind of sneak in
you know dimension reduction without
your users getting confused
so thank you I did mention I'm writing a
book the book will be available for
online access in in June I have a
website if you can see it down there
fight churn with datacom where I'm
posting blog posts made from the the
material I'm preparing for the book and
also you guys can feel free to reach out
to me by any of these means my direct
email connect on LinkedIn follow me on
Twitter and all the source code that I
you that I used to produce these
examples and everything that's gonna be
in the book is all in my public repo on
github I have a minute or two left well
I can take questions but I'll also say
there's so there's so many things I
didn't have time to tell you about it
was really hard deciding you know what
is the one most important thing I can
put into a 40 minute talk I really think
making you know those kind of ratio
metrics is the most important trick I
can convey to you in a short time other
interesting things are well there's a
lot of ways to calculate churn we go
into details of that in the book there's
more kinds of advanced metric tricks you
can do a lot of stuff about preparing
data customer lifetime value is also an
interesting subject and but I'll stop
there and see if anyone wants to ask a
question now do you have any thoughts on
how to distinguish which of these
features might be causal for churn or
retention
yes it's maybe not the answer that
people here are looking for but I never
use any kind of math or statistics to do
it I mean it's usually obvious to I mean
people who know the business the product
creators the customer support people
they're all thinking about this you know
so they're all gonna have their theories
and hypotheses and it's usually just
pretty obvious what's causal and what's
just you know correlative or to the
extent that you can know at all you know
yeah domain expertise can take you far
yeah
could you could you talk a little bit
about windowing of the data so you
presented a lot of metrics that are time
series then presumably before before
comparing them you have to define some
some window
yeah and weigh it against data that is
maybe from a graphic demographic
something that's more of a state rather
than an activity collection over time
yeah well there's two things there I
mean definitely the window that you
choose is important and there's a lot
about this in the book chapter the rule
of thumb is if it's a more if it's a
more rare event you need a longer window
so you get measurements for more people
you know it is if it's something that
happens only rarely you might want to
measure it with like a six-month or a
12-month window in fact if you're an
annual product annual subscriptions you
probably want to measure everything with
a 12-month window but then you've got
the problem of what about new people on
the platform how do you get them a
metric measurement quickly if you want
to use a long window and there's
basically just a scaling trick if you
measure the count per month over a year
you can still call it a count per month
right just divided by 12 then if you
have a new person on the platform you
can make their count per month in just a
month it's still a count per month you
know so it's basically making short
window metrics for new people long
window metrics for people who have been
on for a while and if it's a rare event
where you really want a long window and
then you can just basically use scaling
tricks you know linear scaling to make
to make them all comparable you also
asked about States things like well
demographics and you know industry
they're almost always the least
predictive of churn everyone goes into
this thinking oh I want to know what
industry or what demographic is my best
customers behavior is always way more
predictive and if you do something like
a backward selection I mean I did do
statistics machine learning we do all
that stuff if you do a backward
selection it always Chuck's out the
demographics and keeps the behaviors you
just
it's not not always I mean there are
some cases where you'll find like a good
demographic or firma graphic variable
that explains a lot of churn but they're
usually correlative you know you're like
oh this industry group is churning more
and then you're just like why you know
what's special about them it's not
because you know they're drinking bad
water in you know whatever their
industry is it's because you know they
must be doing something they have a
behavior that's more common in their
industry and you want to get at that
behavior not just leave it at oh I'm bad
with you know thirty five to forty five
year olds you know you want to be like
why am i bad with those people what are
they doing that the other people are not
doing you know what fact about them can
I get to you that's not just their
category yeah so for for behavioral
changes specifically though right
because like if we're talking about
behaviors that's classifying a customer
yeah I pass I am a high call customer I
am a local customer but early on you
talked about the behavior change of a
download all right yeah yeah high to a
low and that's probably personal to me
because you know ten Netflix shows per
week is high for me but it's low for
someone else oh yeah yeah so how do you
define those windows of change and how
do you normalize across cus okay right
sorry I didn't fully understand the
question but that is a really big area
don't have time Fred but you make you
make metrics of change so guess what if
you make a one month window measurement
it's gonna be highly correlated to a
three-month window measurement but if
you take the ratio between your one
month measurement and your three month
measurements in finance they call that a
momentum indicator it's basically just
like the stock price today divided by
the stock price a month ago they call it
you know a momentum ratio but yeah you
make ratios like that and then you get
metrics of change that aren't strongly
correlated with the underlying metrics
so it's another ratio trick that what
it's actually this measuring change over
time is a whole subject yeah in itself
[Music]